so heiß wie ein Joint geraucht wird das
Thema Cannabis Legalisierung diskutiert
die Ampel will Marihuana freigeben da
ist man sich einig immerhin und wie das
ganze aussehen könnte hat
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
heute in Berlin erklärt klar ist eine
Legalisierung könnte die Staatskasse
klingen lassen birgt aber auch Risiken
[Musik]
am Morgen ein Joint und der Tag ist dein
Freund und wenn es nach der Regierung
geht auch bald ganz legal
Bundespressekonferenz 11 Uhr der
Bundesgesundheitsminister stellt vor was
das Kabinett am selben Tag beschlossen
hat das Eckpunktepapier zur
Legalisierung von Cannabis danach soll
klargestellt werden was die
Voraussetzungen sein werden das künftig
straffrei Cannabis produziert werden
kann verkauft werden kann und wieder
besitzt zu regeln ist
kein großer Durchbruch in der
Drogenpolitik zu der Minister eher ein
kleiner Schritt hin zum Gesetz denn das
Eckpunktepapier soll zunächst der
Europäischen Kommission vorgelegt werden
schätzungsweise 4 Millionen Menschen
haben im letzten Jahr in Deutschland
Cannabis konsumiert 25 Prozent der 18
bis 24-Jährigen wir wollen also den
Cannabiskonsum unter Gesundheitsaspekten
reformieren das haben sich mehr als ein
Dutzend
Ressorts an der Entwicklung dieser
Eckpunkte beteiligt aber im Vordergrund
steht der Gesundheitsschutz und der
Gesundheitsschutz ist auch das was wir
heute also
diskutieren zentrales Anliegen der
Regierung dabei der Jugendschutz soll
erweitert werden Vertrieb und Anbau
sollen staatlich kontrolliert werden das
bedeutet wir streben anders also der die
gesamte Menge die hier vertrieben und
auch konsumiert wird dass sie in
Deutschland produziert werden soll also
wir wollen die Produktion also in
Deutschland regulieren lizenzieren und
auch regulieren die sollen so der
Minister vor allem den Schwarzmarkt
trockenlegen ein Plan der nicht
funktionieren kann sagen Experten wie
der auf betäubungsmittelgesetze
spezialisierte Anwalt denn es Schufa
ich glaube nicht dass das gelingen wird
vollständig da eine Entkriminalisierung
zu betreiben wir werden dort sehen wie
das auch in anderen Ländern ist wo das
legalisiert worden ist dass der
Schwarzmarkt natürlich aufblühen wird
weil die Preise natürlich die sich da
erziehen lassen höchstwahrscheinlich
geringer sein werden und deswegen glaube
ich wird sich der Schwarzmarkt gar nicht
vollständig zurückdrängen lassen denn
eines ist klar cannabis ist ein großes
Geschäft auch für den Staat noch gehen
die Schätzungen weit auseinander aber
experten rechnen damit dass die
Legalisierung gut 1,8 Milliarden
Steuergelder pro Jahr in die
Staatskassen spüren würde rechnet man
die Ersparnisse von Kosten der Justiz
und Polizei hinzu so kommen Experten
insgesamt auf die erstaunliche Summe von
4,8 Milliarden Euro Cannabis als legale
Droge damit haben Deutschlands Nachbarn
im Nordwesten 45 Jahre Erfahrung seit
Mitte der 70er Jahre dürfen in den
Niederlanden sogenannte Coffeeshops
Cannabis für den Eigenbedarf verkaufen
aber der Einkauf der Coffeeshops wurde
nie geregelt fruchtbarer Boden für
organisierte Kriminalität wie Marcel
Fink von der holländischen Tageszeitung
Telegraph bestätigt mehr und mehr Leute
weißen jetzt dass das die die Gesundheit
auch in kriminalitätsprobleme sehr groß
sind und und dafür gibt es noch keine
Lösung in den Niederlanden deshalb das
deutsche Gesetz sich im Kern vom
holländischen Vorbild stark
unterscheiden soll wenn man also ist
etwas überspitzt ausdrückt dort die
Nachteile miteinander kommen kombiniert
man hat also quasi einen liberal an der
liberale Nutzung aber keinen
kontrollierten Markt und das wollen wir
eben nicht sondern wir wollen auch auf
der Grundlage der Erfahrung in den
Niederlanden den Markt also sehr also
streng regulieren Anbau regulieren
Qualität regulieren Abgabe regulieren
egal wie und wann die Freigabe kommen
wird eines muss jedem klar sein cannabis
ist und bleibt eine Droge mit all den
bekannten Nebenwirkungen erst am
Mittwoch ist der genau dieses Mercedes
unter Cannabiseinfluss frontal gegen ein
brückenfundament gefahren
[Musik]
es ist das Thema über das heute ganz
Deutschland spricht zudem die CDU
allerdings eine etwas andere Meinung
vertritt als die Ampel
CDU-Bundestagsabgeordneter Philipp
Amthor bei mir im Studio Herr Amthor
herzlich willkommen zunächst einmal ich
fragte sie ganz direkt einige eure
Kollegen gehen ja sehr offen mit dem
Thema um Frau Berger zum Beispiel hat
gesagt glaube ich schon mal an dem Joint
gezogen hat mir aber nicht geschmeckt
wie ist das bei Ihnen schon mal gekifft
naja also ich bin ja auch sozusagen
nicht vom Mond gekommen sondern habe
sozusagen auch studiert wie viele andere
daher bin ich mit dem Thema und den
gesellschaftlichen Diskussionen darum
natürlich auch seit Jahren vertraut ich
weiß auch dass gerade in der jüngeren
Generation das kontrovers diskutiert
wird aber ich will schon sagen wenn man
jetzt auch den Beitrag sieht da wundern
sich viele Bürger zu Hause ich komme
gerade aus meinem Wahlkreis da haben die
Leute riesenwirtschaftliche sorgen und
das was die Ampel irgendwie zum Thema
des Tages macht ist die Legalisierung
von Cannabis das ist schon eine wirklich
sehr sehr merkwürdige Schwerpunktsetzung
sie haben gesagt sie sind damit in
Beruhigung gekommen haben sie jetzt
gekifft oder nicht
also ich habe da keine große
Begeisterung für entfaltet für das ganze
Thema und ich finde vor allem wir müssen
hier in der gesamten Diskussion jetzt
rund um die Cannabis Legalisierung auch
wirklich mal klar sein das ist doch
nicht so ein Gefühls Thema was hält
jetzt der einzelne Politiker irgendwie
von Cannabis ja nein sondern es muss
doch auch darum gehen wie gehen wir um
mit der Kriminalität die sich damit auch
verbindet was passiert eigentlich wird
jetzt diese
Drogenkriminalität die wir im Moment
haben verschwindet die löst sie sich
durch die Legalisierung in Luft auf ich
glaube nicht und auch das Thema Kinder
und Jugendschutz kommt da ein bisschen
zu kurz und deswegen glaube ich geht's
weniger so um emotionale Gefühligkeit
sondern das müssen wir faktenbasiert
diskutieren Cannabis und riesengroßer
Markt aber wird auf mehrere Milliarden
geschätzt einige sprechen von fünf
andere wiederum von 8 bis 12 das könnte
aber viel viel Geld für den Staat
bedeuten wollen sie das dann einfach so
liegen lassen also ich wünsche mir
eigentlich eine Bundesregierung die er
Maßnahmen dafür trifft dass die
Wirtschaft in diesem Land wieder läuft
dass es Steuereinnahmen gibt und die
nicht irgendwie auf die finanziellen
Verzückung einer cannabisbesteuerung
setzt natürlich ist klar wenn man diese
Legalisierung macht ist auch die
Besteuerung von Cannabis nur konsequent
aber am Ende um staatliche Einnahmen zu
haben um den Doppel Wumms und andere
Dinge die Olaf Scholz Personen
Schaufenster stellt zu finanzieren dafür
brauchen wir eine Wirtschaft die
funktioniert und nicht irgendwelche
Einnahmen aus Cannabis erlösen schauen
wir noch mal auf ein anderes Thema über
das heute ja viel diskutiert wurde
ausgerechnet Audi Chef Markus düsmann
fordert angesichts der Energiekrise
folgendes um uns in Deutschland besser
einzustimmen auf die Lage und die
Notwendigkeit des Sparens könnte es
wieder autofreie Tage geben sowie in den
1970er Jahren das sagte der Süddeutschen
Zeitung auch ein Tempolimit könne ein
hilfreiches Symbol sein auf der anderen
Seite gibt Audi gerade heute den
Einstieg in die Formel 1 bekannt alles
andere als umweltfreundlich Wasser
predigen aber Wein trinken was sagen sie
dazu Herr Amthor
haben wir es hier mit Bigotterie zu tun
also ich finde diese Diskussion über so
ein autofreien Sonntag die kann man als
Vorstandsvorsitzender von Audi ganz
locker führen da hat er Gefühle ich
gesagt würde er gerne mit seinem Rennrad
dann mal am Sonntag über die Frauen
freien Autobahn fahren das kann man
vielleicht als Vorstandsvorsitzender von
Audi bei mir zu Hause im ländlichen Raum
im Mecklenburg-Vorpommern fassen sich da
viele Leute an den Kopf dass es anders
als hier in der Großstadt mit S-Bahn von
A nach B oder am besten irgendwie so ein
entspannter Sonntag mit dem Rennrad
viele Leute brauchen für Mobilität
gerade im ländlichen Raum das Auto und
deswegen finde ich kann man da schon
sagen na ja irgendwie vor Bayern eine
Lebensrealitäten und zweiter Punkt den
man glaube ich auch machen muss ist
natürlich schon das ist schön dass Audi
das jetzt fordert für Deutschland dieses
Thema könnte man gerne mal in China
aufmachen wo sie die großen Absätze
machen uns wollen sie die Vorschriften
machen das passt doch nicht zusammen
exakt der größte Absatzmarkt China für
VW für Audi für Mercedes für BMW meinen
sie würde so einen Vorschlag gemacht
werden von dem Audi Boss oder oder ist
das vielleicht ein naja reiten auf der
Welle des Zeitgeistes ja das ist genau
die gute Beschreibung reiten auf der
Welle des Zeitgeistes der neudeutsche
Begriff dafür heißt ja Greenwashing ja
das kommt dann gut an wenn man in die
Formel 1 einsteigt und gleichzeitig sagt
ja in Deutschland kann man doch mal ein
autofreien Sonntag machen ich finde das
passt nicht wirklich zusammen und ich
glaube die allermeisten Leute
durchschauen das auch und gerade eine
Firma wie Audi die lebt doch auch von
der Begeisterung fürs Auto und nicht
irgendwie von diesen grünen verbotsideen
und deswegen finde ich sollte man da
irgendwie die Kirche im Dorf lassen bei
diesem Thema bleiben wir beim Thema
China
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat gegen den
Willen von sechs Bundesministerien einen
china-deal im Hamburger Hafen
durchgeboxt die chinesische
staatsräderei cosco darf 24,9% eines
Containerterminals im Hamburger Hafen
übernehmen wen hier bald die Flaggen
Chinas wie gefährlich ist der Deal für
Deutschland
ich gebe die Frage direkt weiter er ist
sehr gefährlich und das ist eine klare
Fehlentscheidung des Bundeskanzlers hier
entpuppte sich in gewisser Weise als
eine Art scholzzettung ja er stellt hier
die Interessen Chinas über unsere
eigenen souveränitätsinteressen und der
Bundeskanzler hat von einer Zeitenwende
gesprochen mit Blick auf Russland und
gerade was wir mit Blick auf Russland
gelernt haben wie stark wir uns abhängig
gemacht haben beim Thema Gas aber auch
beim Thema Infrastrukturen der Einstieg
russischer Unternehmen unsere
Gasspeicher anderes mehr das muss uns
doch bei China jetzt die klare Lehre
sein dass wir so nicht weitermachen
können und da hat er auch seine
Koalitionspartner mächtig vor den Kopf
gestoßen ich halte das für eine
Fehlentscheidung Friedrich Merz hat es
auch in den Clan und notwendigen Worten
kritisiert es waren Alleingang vom
Bundeskanzler sechs Ministerien haben
sich dagegen ausgesprochen andere
könnten man könnte jetzt auch sagen der
hat seinen Mann entstand gestanden hat
sich durchgesetzt sie sagen eher er hat
seine Minister und Ministerin enteiert
ja das kann man in gewisser Weise so
sagen das Problem ist natürlich schon
und ich finde es ja eher ein Wert dass
da Olaf Scholz sozusagen jetzt im
Widerstreit ist mit dem Ministern und
das bärbock das Habeck das Buschmann von
der FDP dass die eine andere Meinung
haben finde ich gut aber am Ende haben
sie sich nicht durchsetzen können und
das ist jetzt schon das zweite Mal wir
haben es gesehen beim Thema Kernkraft
wir sehen jetzt hier die basta Politik
und da muss man sie schon fragen wie
viel Selbstachtung haben FDP und Grüne
eigentlich noch und ich glaube das ist
kein gutes Zeichen für ein vernünftiges
Diskussionsklima in einer Koalition
kommt nach der SPD Russland connection
mit Gerhard Schröder als
erklärt wie er gerne genannt wird und
manuell Leser Manuela Schwesig als
pipeline-patin jetzt China Schulz naja
wir müssen zumindest schauen dass Olaf
Scholz jetzt hier auch mal deutsche
Interessen in den Vordergrund stellt er
reist jetzt nach Peking in einem
Alleingang Immanuel macron wollte
eigentlich mit den hat er dann mal eben
quasi ausgeladen reist alleine und
bringt dann noch irgendwie den
Machthabern in Peking als Geschenk jetzt
diese quasi Genehmigung der Beteiligung
für den Hamburger Hafen mit das passt
nicht zusammen und wie gesagt da muss
Olaf Scholz aufpassen dass er sich hier
nicht zu Scholz Sitzungen Maus hat und
bei Bild und viele andere Menschen auf
der Welt bewegt noch ein anderes Thema
dieses hier
auch 40 Tage nach dem grausamen Mord an
Marsa Amini gehen die Proteste gegen das
molaregime weiter die Sittenpolizei
hatte die junge Frau festgenommen weil
sie gegen die islamischen
Kleidungsvorschriften verstoßen haben
soll am 16 September starb sie in
Polizei Gewahrsam seit ihrem Tod
demonstrieren weltweit hunderttausende
gegen den repressiven Kurs des brutalen
unterdrückerregims macht Deutschland
genug dagegen wo bleibt Außenministerin
Annalena baerbocks feministische
Außenpolitik
feministische Außenpolitik im Politik im
Koalitionsvertrag beschlossen eine
Außenpolitik die die Belange der Frauen
weltweit in den Fokus nimmt das wäre
doch jetzt eigentlich die Gelegenheit
für Annalena bärburg oder wie sehen Sie
das so ist es Überschriften wie diese
die feministische Außenpolitik die sind
nicht nur etwas für schön wetterzeiten
sondern die müssen dann auch konkret
werden und hier sehen wir dieses Thema
gerade dieser wirklich Schlag ins
Gesicht für die Frauenrechte in der
ganzen Welt wir haben das klar
kritisiert als
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion und die
Außenministerin die hat tagelang
geschwiegen und es passt doch nicht
zusammen irgendwie Friedrich Merz
vorzuwerfen er würde keine feministische
Außenpolitik machen und dann wenn man es
selbst tun könnte als Außenministerin in
Deckung zu gehen das ist zu wenig und
ich hätte mir gerade von Annalena
baerbock bei diesem Thema viel mehr
handeln erwartet das ist nicht gekommen
und das bleibt aus wir klären sie sich
das dass die die Proteste im Iran jetzt
quasi zum Stresstest werden ja ich frage
mich was da irgendwie die Regierung
hemmt wir haben es ja an vielen Stellen
gesehen dass die Dinge nicht
zusammenpassen der Bundespräsident
frühere SPD außenminister Steinmeier hat
sich da merkwürdig verhalten den Mullahs
quasi gratuliert und immer wieder in den
vergangenen Jahren haben wir
insbesondere aus den Reihen der SPD
manche Zweideutigkeit erlebt das halte
ich für falsch wir müssen sehen dass
dieses System ein Problem für die
Menschenrechte weltweit ist und das muss
man auch klar benennen und das muss auch
in einer Werte geleiteten Außenpolitik
die die Ampel so gerne propagiert zum
Ausdruck kommen das fehlte momentchen
werden hingerichtet Frauen unterdrückt
Demonstranten weg gesperrt das Regime
bedroht Israel mit Atomwaffen und
fördert Terrorismus auf der ganzen Welt
was kann muss Deutschland jetzt tun für
die Menschen im Iran und gegen die Molas
wir müssen ein ganz klares Stoppsignal
senden auch mit Sanktionen dass es
notwendig denn dieses Regime dass ich
immer so glaubenstreu gibt es natürlich
trotzdem von Leuten umgeben die gerne
die Vorzüge der restlichen Welt von
gesundheitsbehandlungen bis zu
Shoppingtrips nutzen da muss ein Riegel
vorgeschoben werden es braucht klare und
wirksame Sanktionen gegen die Machthaber
gegen die mullas und Ihr System und wir
müssen auch deutlich machen und das ist
gerade mit Blick auf die nukleare
Bedrohung auch für Israel und andere
notwendig dass wir da gar keinen Raum
für Missverständnisse lassen sondern
eine klare Haltung in der Außenpolitik
an den Tag legen da würde ich mir viel
mehr Entschlossenheit von Annalena
baerbockwunsch ich möchte Ihnen noch was
zeigen ein Tweet von unserem
bildchefredakteur Johannes Boje der hat
getwittert der terrorstadt Iran hat
meine Kollegin Alexandra würzbach und
mich auf eine Sanktionsliste gesetzt die
Angst vor freier Presse und die Wut über
unsere Iran Berichterstattung
moosgrenzenlos sein ein Satz dazu von
Ihnen noch ja man kann fast sagen
Glückwunsch dazu dass Johannes Boje an
der Stelle klares Profil zeigt von sowas
darf man sich nicht einschüchtern lassen
wir müssen hier die Pressefreiheit
verteidigen und am Ende wenn man auf der
Sanktionsliste dieser Mullahs steht ist
das eigentlich eher ein Prädikat dafür
dass man für westliche Werte streitet
und das muss von uns als
Gesamtgesellschaft auch erwartet werden
noch was ein bisschen lockeres zum
Schluss wir zeigen gleich hier in der
Sendung einen schönen Beitrag über
Männer die sehr stolz auf ihre
Bierbäuche sind Männlichkeit ist ja ein
großes Thema definiert irgendwie jeder
mittlerweile anders was ist Männlichkeit
für Sie was bedeutet das ach da gehört
viel dazu ich glaube jetzt würde ich da
nicht irgendwie in Schlagworten agieren
mal einen Bier zu trinken gehört
vielleicht dazu aber ich glaube wir sind
schon in einer gleichberechtigten Welt
und das auch gut so und da müssen wir
glaube ich nicht über Männlichkeit und
anderes diskutieren stolze Bierbäuche
immerhin ich bin gespannt auf den
Beitrag vielen Dank für den Besuch
Philipp Amthor
[Musik]